there were a lot of interesting trends
this year in the space of artificial
intelligence an industry that will
likely grow to 500 billion dollars of
investment by 2024 and of course we
continue to see lots of interesting new
companies working on autonomous driving
and that's exactly what wabi is doing
wabi is a more recent arrival in the
self-driving driverless vehicle space
the company is led by raquel erdison an
interesting and very experienced
computer scientist a professor at the
university of toronto she was also chief
scientist for uber's autonomous vehicle
program
but in 2021 she struck out on her own
with her own company wabi
we see a lot of consolidation in the
industry approaches are very similar and
there is you know very slow progress uh
where you know every solving every
single problem becomes more and more
difficult so we really needed a
diversity of new thinking in order to
solve this complex problem and that's
why the best way to really start new
technology is to start afresh and fund a
new company
so if you look at
you know what has happened in the
industry in self-driving since the darpa
challenge which is almost two decades
ago
we see that you know there is been
meaningful progress but when it comes to
deployment and commercialization we see
very little you know very small
operation domains and
you know something that is you know very
far from the promise of driving
everywhere so this is why wabi is
looking at solving self-driving in a new
way where we are bringing an ai first
approach where instead of ai being you
know somewhere using the stock it's
really at the forefront really
unleashing all the power of ai to solve
in all these complex problems together
with this ai first approach we have a
simulation-centric approach that
basically enables us to be much faster
much safer and much less capital
intensive than our competitors and don't
rely on driving millions of miles in the
real world in order to really test our
systems instead we do this in the
simulator which is you know much safer
much more efficient
wabi is setting itself apart to some
extent from previous av companies
because erdeson views it as a much more
ai intensive form of autonomous driving
development and what that means is a
much greater emphasis on simulation
testing
vast numbers of vehicles
traveling incalculable miles in virtual
reality in a simulator there will be
some on-road testing but the bigger
focus is really advanced simulation to
accelerate the pace of development
our approach is very different which is
with wobby wool
which is our simulator is you know next
generation
where it really mimics how
you know how the real world driving uh
works where uh it's an immersive and
reactive environment you can think of it
as you know you are testing the entire
software stuck
in the simulator and it's in a way that
for uh
you know for the brain of the cell
driving vehicle looks the same as if it
was in the real world so we can create
digital twins of the real world we can
create you know all the possible
scenarios that might happen and then
basically test uh you know the entire
system to see how it will react if any
of these scenarios might
happen in the real world so it's a
generation of technology that nobody has
apart from having
wabi is going to move into autonomous
trucking which has turned out to be
one of the really hot spaces in av
development
because of the ongoing shortage in truck
drivers especially on long-haul routes
the somewhat greater simplicity of
driving on highways versus dense urban
environments and just the ever expanding
demand for goods delivery and shipping
raquel stands out as one of the few
women to start an autonomous vehicle
company women are making progress
generally in the ai space although they
are still clearly in the minority
however when it comes to autonomous
vehicle companies we do see women
showing up in greater numbers than they
might in other areas of tech
in order to solve such a complex problem
as self-driving you need a diversity of
opinions and in order to
have the diversity of opinions then you
need a diverse team and i think this is
something that
you know the field the industry
needs to do a much better job and this
is something that you know
we care a lot about that wabi and we
really believe that is in the collective
power of all of us that we actually will
come up with the best solutions forward
so the av space is a very rich area for
artificial intelligence activity and
wabi is one of the companies that we
felt really
earned recognition this year given its
fundraising and its rapid pace of
development in this space it's been an
incredible journey and there is nothing
better than funding a company with the
people that you love to work with
so i will say that you know despite the
difficulties and things along the way
this has been an amazing ride and i can
be more proud of
you know the team and what they have
accomplished
[Music]
you